here's a tree man what's his he's in
he's an ant but I his name is tree beard
you know him as John Kerry I call him
Treebeard from The Lord of the Rings
movies over there uh here is John
carrier former climates are under Barack
Obama who's now still flying all over
the country and all over the world in
his private jet uh here he is explaining
a bit about climate change to the people
of congress you asked the question
what's it going to look like
that depends on what we decide to do
it's very obvious that there are huge
threats here literally food production
for an entire continent could implode
water is already diminishing last year
the Rhine River was down to inches they
had to stop navigation on the river
because of that you're seeing glaciers
that are now absolutely predictable as
to when they will be completely gone
and and at the rate the ice is melding
in the north and south of Antarctic
Antarctica
there are dire predictions now about how
that's moved forward by about 30 years
at the pace at which the the it is
Vanishing uh and parts of the Earth are
warming much faster than other parts of
the Earth the Arctic for instance is
warming four times faster than the rest
of the earth other places are we're
hitting heat levels in places that have
never been lived by human beings so on a
regular basis
oh no heat levels in places that humans
have never lived I guess they're going
to continue not to live there look
everything he said there is nonsense
this jackass flies his private jet all
over the world they live in a way that
they would never allow you to live you
have nothing to worry about and don't
worry they're not worried about it
either which is why Barack Obama lives
on a 30-acre estate on the water in
Martha's Vineyard don't worry no illegal
immigrants over there but now here's the
kicker of this freaking thing they asked
John Kerry about him flying his own
private jet around the world to talk
about climate change and you will just
love this freaking answer
so uh I just don't agree with your facts
which began with the presentation of one
of the most outrageously persistent lies
that I hear which is this private jet we
don't own a private jet I don't own a
private jet I personally have never
owned a private jet and obviously it's
pretty stupid to talk about coming in a
private jet from the state department up
here
just honestly if that's where you want
to go go there
a few moments later you uh just
testified under oath that you never
owned a private jet Mr chairman I'd like
to enter into the record uh article here
from February 15th of 2000 2023 the John
Kerry family private jet was sold
shortly after accusations of climate
hypocrisy Mr secretary you stand by that
testimony that you've never owned or I
personally family
personally yes my wife owned a plan
[Music]
oh oh I completely forgot my wife on the
plane yeah yeah yeah yeah
also he's a lizard person do you notice
how when he talks the tongue
it keeps popping out of it
I never rode a plane
oh my whiteboard
I can't take these people I cannot take
it I cannot take it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]